à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
patates pilées faut trop d'écho compter
bien sûr faux toi et moi d'être de
retour
attention il vous manque un
[Musique]
c'est que c'est lourd oh qu'est ce que
c'est que ça les haltères pour me faire
des muscles tu mets prat mais c'est bien
trop lourd pour toi allez battant laisse
moi faire ma gymnastique
et
oh je commencerais tout à l'heure ne
parlons pas en noir à manches à balai le
tour est joué
[Musique]
c'est pas possible c'est pas le plus
grand qui sont les plus fins des mains
[Musique]
sales
mais tu as sûrement un secret bien sûr
lequel six un secret c'est que ça ne
sera pas pas aux pâtes à zut je t'en
prie
dis moi ton secret tiens je te promet de
réparer nos chariots dès ce soir je
mange chaque matin de couronnes de
beasain gouin a des gars de quoi de
blizzard way demi je vais immédiatement
en acheter
euros
et oh
rabat le grand désarroi ça n'existe pas
où je peux essayer pas où tu m'as bien
sûr mais surtout quand moi aussi je suis
d'accord aux haltères
[Musique]
roux oulala meyrin tazoult tu as un
secret c'est même un très grand secret
dis-le moi 5 1 dans les jambes au lit
c'est cher attend tous est donc bon eh
eh bien je t'écoute le crâne de busan
voire trois fois par jour
[Musique]
oh
et
encore un des travaux à la pâte a dû
[Musique]
batailler
j'ai fait tous les magasins de la ville
je n'ai pas trouvé de graines de beasain
gouin je suis seul à m'avoir talla là je
suis là en arabe
mata zut j'ai trouvé le secret du
blizzard points semblent quant à nora
n'oublie pas que tu veux toi 5 caramel
bien 3g vous qu'il y ait deux pattes
opus ne faut trompez pas notez bien sur
vos droits votre attention
ils ont mon coeur
[Musique]